welcome back
so we've learned that it's important to
keep working through your frustrations
by using the right learning strategies
the more you work through your
frustration the more your brain grows
right
but it can be difficult to work through
that frustration without a clear
direction that's why it's important to
make smart goals it's an acronym goes
like this
specific
measurable
actionable realistic
timely because look you can wish all you
want and say one day i'm gonna go to the
moon and you can want that like your
life depended on it but a wish is not a
goal an example of a moon plan that
consists of smart goals would go
something like this
in 20 years i will have studied enough
physics and chemistry flown jet planes
in the air force worked out four times a
week and gotten a job as an astronaut
for nasa and this will enable me to fly
a spacecraft to the moon and put my feet
on it for science reasons specific
put your feet on the moon
measurable are your feet touching the
surface of the moon
actionable it is actionable that is to
say doable to study physics and
chemistry enlist in the air force and go
to the gym
realistic
it's hard but it's not impossible to
become an astronaut
timely here's where more realism kicks
in you won't be able to go to the moon
as an astronaut overnight 20 years seems
a little more reasonable but let's take
this back to a more sensible time scale
and look at our friend thinky pinky hey
buddy
tp here is interested in pull-ups wants
to be able to lift their entire mass
with just the arms this one but pull-ups
are hard
so let's take a look at thinky pinky's
reflection journal
quote
i want to be able to do two consecutive
pull-ups by the end of the year by
practicing pull-ups at the gym three
times per week
why is this a smart goal
s is for specific
tp wants to work on pull-ups and they're
not interested in biking or weight
training there's one skill that thinky
pinky wants to work on and that's
pull-ups
m is for measurable what's the metric
for tp's success two in a row two
pull-ups one right after the other
you've either done it or you haven't
measurable
a is for actionable can it be broken
down into individual tasks yeah going to
the gym three times a week to practice
feels very actionable indeed
r is for realistic tp's not training to
lift a car
just some pull-ups
t is for timely there's a time limit on
this
thinky pinky wants to do this in a
year's time
all together that's a smart goal you got
there tp
with the power of persistence smart
goals and the right kind of help you can
do anything you set your mind to
you can learn anything
happy goal setting